in this half-hour with pressure to
prescribe if you've spent time as a
hospital patient you may recall
receiving a survey about your experience
well it turns out your answers can
impact how much the hospital is paid and
in some cases even what your doctor
earns the government-mandated patient
satisfaction survey is meant to reward
quality care but some doctors say it's
had an unintended consequence fueling
Americans dependence on prescription
painkillers brook silva-braga is here
with the Storybrooke good morning good
morning Anthony and Alex these surveys
are part of the major effort in American
medicine to pay for effective care
rather than just how many procedures are
performed and many health care providers
say the surveys are helping to do that
but a handful of the questions are
raising concerns because doctors say
they seem to encourage the prescription
of pain pills Brooke we met dr. mark
Woodard in the ER at Bristol Regional
Medical Center in eastern Tennessee
Apalachee is ground zero for the
country's opioid abuse crisis 2 million
americans are hooked on pain pills
overdoses kill more people than gun
homicides on the shift you're getting
off now did you see anyone seeking drugs
oh yes I'm every shift I mean two or
three today but turning away drug
seekers can be bad for business doctors
told us in part because of the rise of
patient satisfaction surveys in addition
to asking if the nurses are polite and
the hospital is clean the survey has
questions like how often did the
hospital staff do everything they could
to help you with your pain twenty-eight
percent of doctors are paid bonuses
based on patient satisfaction according
to the industry group physicians
practice and hospitals with better
scores get bigger payments from Medicare
and Medicaid do any of you think these
scores are leading to more prescriptions
being written yes oh yes definitely do
you think it's leading to more people
becoming addicted of course yes yes
doctors Dana Barlow Ramon Ibrahim and
Joe Smitty have practice medicine in
Appalachia for a combined 98 years and
say more and more of their patients have
become addicted it's getting worse year
after year the administrator will come
up dr. Barlow says pressure on hospitals
to score well let
the pressure on doctors including him to
prescribe opioids and how does that
conversation go well it goes basically
we want to make sure that everybody in
the mergency department is happy and and
their pain is relieved and so you need
to do that do they say let's get the
scores up they tell you to get the
scores up yeah I've seen physicians
fired because of not adequately
addressing pain management researchers
at the University of Wisconsin found one
in five doctors reported their jobs had
been threatened over the scores some of
them have ended up looking for work here
at the clinic dr. Smitty runs we see
physician applicants who have lost their
previous job because of the prescribing
habits that were placed upon them that
they weren't comfortable with in a
previous job in response to similar
concerns Medicare and Medicaid will stop
paying hospitals based on their pain
scores beginning october first but many
hospitals will still use the scores to
rate their doctors using reports created
by private survey companies dr. jim
merlino is the president of strategic
consulting for the biggest of those
companies press ganey he says comparing
physicians makes doctors more
accountable let's say your physician
that doesn't believe in giving a lot of
pain medication are you going to allow a
patient to sit in bed writhing in pain
would you allow that I wouldn't I would
want to know as a provider as a leader
of a group or a hospital if that was
happening in my patients so you do think
it's fine for doctors to be compared to
other doctors based on these scores I
think that getting data points out to
physicians is important yes we talked
about satisfaction scores every day back
in Tennessee Woodard who leads a group
of ER doctors has negotiated a
compromise with his hospital when
patient satisfaction bonuses are
calculated questions on pain are
stripped out why would you care about
not being graded on pain what difference
would it make if you were well because
it would put us under pressure do i
write this patient a small amount of
narcotics where they'll be happy with me
and give me a good score where i can
either keep my job or get a financial
bonus i think human nature says you're
under pressure to do that doctors groups
told us those type of arrangements that
ignore the pain questions are becoming
more common
but with no national rules about how the
scores are used it remains a hospital by
Hospital decision on what to do about
doctors with low pain management scores
Anthony brook silva-braga fascinating
thanks bro